[Music]
set the stage for what is probably the
most likable super villain in film
history this year we can finally look
forward to part four of the Despicable
Me film series of course grew and his
adopted daughters are back along with Dr
nefario Silas Rams bottom and Gru's wife
Lucy and needless to say the minions
will also be there find out all the
latest information about the eagerly
awaited sequel in this video
the Despicable Mei franchise which
currently comprises five movies
including the minion spin-offs is
regarded as extremely successful and has
grossed over $4.6 billion to date so
it's no wonder that illumination and
Universal Pictures want to build on
these gigantic results even before the
movie is released it is safe to say that
the fourth adventure of grw and his
friends will also prove to be highly
profitable part four is set to follow on
from from the previous movie according
to initial information so far details
have been kept Under Wraps nevertheless
the finale of Despicable Me 3 gives us
some initial Clues as to what the new
movie could be about Gru wants to leave
his old Life as a villain behind and
devote himself fully to his family his
brother Drew however sees things very
differently in the closing credits of
part three we see him once again setting
off on a criminal mission in the company
of the minions the sequel is therefore
likely to present guu with the difficult
task of having to hunt down his own
brother actress Miranda Cosgrove who
voices Gru's eldest adopted daughter
Margot said she would be interested in a
different story she suggested the
possibility that Margot and her sisters
could pursue a career as super villains
themselves the cast of Despicable Me 4
already indicates that all the important
characters will be returning comedy
Legend Steve Carell will once again take
on the main character Gru and his
brother Drew true I Carly star Miranda
Cosgrove will voice Margot again while
Diana G and Nev Cheryl will voice Edith
and Agnes Kristen wig will be back in
the role of Gru's wife Lucy we can also
look forward to the return of Steve
cougan silus Rams bottom while Pierre
coffin will be voicing The Lovable
minions illumination has once again
succeeded in securing Chris renod as a
director renod has previously acquired
some experience in the animation genre
and in addition to the first first two
Despicable Me films he also directed The
Lorax as well as the secret life of pets
and the secret life of pets 2 the
screenplay was penned by Mike White who
is best known for the Acclaim series The
White Lotus and the last illumination
Adventure migration illumination founder
Chris melandre will return as producer
it could also be interesting to see who
will be responsible for the Musical part
of the movie this time with the Oscar
nominated song Happy farell Williams has
undoubtedly done a good job but we can
of course assume that the the minions
will also be performing their versions
of well-known pop songs
again based on current information we
can expect to see Gru's new adventure in
theater starting on July 3rd 2024
current rumors suggests that we can also
look forward to the first trailer for
Despicable mi4 at the Super Bowl on
February 11th we already got a first
glimpse of the minions with the short
film Moon Back In December which further
increased the anticipation for the next
installment and that's it for our little
update now wouldd like to know what you
guys expect from the movie is a trip to
the cinema a given for you or are you
fed up with the franchise let us know
your thoughts in the
[Music]
comments